البحر المتوسط مقبره طالب اللجوء بواحده
من اكثر طرق الهجره واللجوء خطوره لقي
كثير من الاشخاص حتفهم لدى كل واحد قصه
وامل وحلم
تحطمت جميعها على الصخور
وتقاذفتها الامواج بين مد وجزر
هذه ماساه هجره اخرى ترسم ملامحها على
ضفاف المتوسط جثه طفله تطفو على سطح الماء
قباله السواحل الشرقيه لتونس لا تزال ام
الطفله مفقوده بعد ان حال بينهما الموت
حفر السواحل التونسي قال ان مركبين يقلان
عشرات المهاجرين غير نظاميين من دول
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء غرق الاربعاء
الماضيه قبلات السواحل صفاقس وجزيره قرقنه
بعضهم من براثن الامواج الهادره مشهد
يختزل عجز طالب اللجوء وانعدام الامل في
الجهود لانهاء ازمتهم تشير التوقعات الى
انه في الاشهر المقبله سيعبر كثير من طالب
اللجوء المتوسط دون ان يعرفوا ما يخبئه
لهم مستقبل الحكومه الايطاليه المناهضه
لهذه الظاهره شددت من الضوابط لوقف تدفقهم
حتى باستهداف السفن الاغاثه التي تهب
لنجدتهم عند الغرق كحاله هاتين السفينتين
التابعتين لمنظمات غير حكوميه المانيه
لانقاذ المهاجرين في المتوسط فقد تعرضت
للحجز بسبب مخالفتهما قانونا صدقت عليه
روما مطلع يناير كانون الثاني الماضي
فرض القانون على سفن منظمات الانقاذ ابلاغ
السلطات الايطاليه فور اسعاف زورق وترك
القانون لخفر السواحل سلطه تحديد الميناء
الذي سينزل فيه الناجون والمزعفون جلب
القانون انتقادات للحكومه اليمينيه بقياده
جورجيا ميلوني لانه غالبا ما تخصص موانئ
بعيده جدا عن مواقع الانقاذ وتخسر فرق
الانقاذ كثيرا من الوقت للابحار الى
الموانئ المخصصه والعوده الى اعالي البحار
حسب ما يقول منتقدون ومع ذلك سجل وصول
اكثر من 47 الفا من طالب اللجوء الى
ايطاليا حتى الان خلال العام الجاري تاخذ
روما على شركائها في الاتحاد الاوروبي عدم
تضامنهم في توزيع هؤلاء على الرغم من ان
عدد كبير منهم يغادر ايطاليا لاحقا الى
دول اخرى